10 years of car payments and I'm so over
it but he just thinks we should upgrade
to the biggest one which is the Yukon
right now we have a a GMC aadia so he's
wanting more why do you need to why do
you need to upgrade the big reason would
just be more room uh we have four kids
and um so there's really no trunk space
you do know they have large SUVs that
are cheaper than 20 don't you yes does
he uh yes he does so part of the problem
is we are not on baby step 2 you are
he's one of to stay into debt it sounds
like he's trading in one car payment for
a slightly bigger car payment told him
you know um you know the way Ramsey does
it is we cash flow and then we trade it
in and then we pay the difference and
he's like well why don't we just do that
now and then pay it off um all at once
but I'm like no I'm so ready to be done
and he's like it's just 3,000 more and
I'm like well that's just well the
Dealer's not going to give you 22 for
you trade it in